LINE WAS TOO BLURRED THERE.
BUT CERTAINLY THE EVENING MORE
OPINION SHOWS.
>> YOU KNOW, STEPHANIE, WE'VE
TALKED A LOT.
WE TALKED AFTER YOUR BOOK CAME
OUT ABOUT YOU REFLECTING ON YOUR
ROLE IN THE TRUMP
ADMINISTRATION.
YOU'VE SAID THINGS LIKE YOU'RE
NOT SURE THAT YOU WILL EVER BE
REDEEMED FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
IN THE TRUMP ADMINISTRATION.
YOU KNOW, YOU REALLY HAVE SOUL
SEARCHED IN THE WAKE OF LEAVING.
I DO WONDER WHAT YOU THINK IS
NEXT AND IF THERE'S ANYTHING
THAT YOU CAN SHED LIGHT ON ON
WHAT COMES AHEAD?
.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
AND I'MST ILL NOT LOOKING FOR
REDEMPTION.
I'M ACTUALLY JUST LOOKING
FORWARD.
I'VE BEEN WATCHING THIS PAST
YEAR, AS THE PRESIDENT CONTINUES
TO MANIPULATE PEOPLE AND DIVIDE
OUR COUNTRY BECAUSE HE HAS A
FRAGILE EGO.
THAT'S ALL THERE IS TO IT.
NEXT WEEK A GROUP OF FORMER
TRUMP STAFF ARE GOING TO COME
TOGETHER.
ADMINISTRATION OFFICIALS ARE
GOING TO COME TOGETHER AND TALK
ABOUT HOW WE CAN FORMALLY DO
THINGS TO TRY AND STOP HIM AND
ALSO, YOU KNOW, THE EXTREMISM,
THAT KIND OF VIOLENCE AND
RHETORIC THAT HAS BEEN TALKED
ABOUT AND CONTINUES TO DIVIDE
OUR COUNTRY.
I MYSELF AM HOPING TO TRAVEL THE
COUNTRY AND TALK TO PEOPLE WHO
ARE BELIEVERS, LIKE I ONCE WAS.
AND I WANT PEOPLE TO UNDERSTAND
WHO HE IS.
HE CARES ABOUT NO ONE BUT
HIMSELF.
I THINK A REALLY GOOD EXAMPLE OF
THAT IS, YOU KNOW, THE PEOPLE
WHO HAVE BEEN RIGHTFULLY
PUNISHED FOR THEIR ROLE IN THE
INSURRECTION.
WHERE IS HE?
ALL I KNOW IS HE'S SITTING AT
MAR-A-LAGO APPARENTLY GETTING
HIS LEGAL BILLS PAID BY THE RNC
WHEN THIS MAN IS A MASTER
MANIPULATOR.
HE GETS PEOPLE TO DO HIS
BIDDING.
I WAS ONE OF THEM.
AND I WANT PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE IN
HIM NOW TO TALK TO ME.
AND I WANT TO EXPLAIN WHO HE
REALLY IS.
SO I'M REALLY HOPING FOR A GOOD
FIGHT IN 2022.
I'M READY TO ROLL UP MY SLEEVES
AND DO WHAT I CAN.
I'M EXCITED TO GET WITH THESE
FORMER TRUMP OFFICIALS AND DO
SOME GREAT THINGS.
>> WHICH FORMER TRUMP OFFICIALS?
>> I'M NOT GOING TO GET AHEAD OF
THAT.
WE WILL BE ANNOUNCING THAT IN
THE COMING WEEKS.
IT SHOULD BE VERY SIGNIFICANT.
WE'RE REALLY, REALLY EXCITED.
>> CAN YOU TELL ME HOW MANY OF
YOU ARE GOING TO GET-TOGETHER?
>> ABOUT 15 RIGHT NOW.
>> AND IS THIS PEOPLE WHO WERE
WORKING INSIDE THE WHITE HOUSE
ITSELF?
>> SOME OF THEM, YES.
>> SENIOR TO YOU, JUNIOR TO YOU?
BOTH?
>> WELL, I WAS -- I MEAN, IT
DEPENDS WHAT LEVEL?
I WAS CHIEF OF STAFF.
RIGHT THERE WOULD BE JUNIOR TO
ME.
BUT BOTH.
>> THAT IS INTERESTING.
HOW DID THIS COME TOGETHER?
HOW DID THIS GROUP OF FORMER, AS
YOU SAY, ADMIN IS STATION
OFFICIALS, WHO ARE NOW GOING TO
MEET TO FIGURE OUT A WAY TO
PREVENT TRUMP FROM RE-TAKING
OFFICE.
HOW DID THIS MEETING COME TO
PASS?
>> I THINK THAT THERE WERE A FEW
OF US WHO, AGAIN, HAVE BEEN
SITTING BACK WATCHING HIM
CONTINUE TO MANIPULATE AND
SPREAD THIS BIG LIE AND CONTINUE
TO HARM OUR COUNTRY.
AND STARTED SOME INFORMAL CHATS.
AND THEN STARTED THROWING AROUND
IDEAS OF WHAT WE COULD DO, HOW
WE COULD FORMIZE IT, STARTED
OUTREACH TO OTHER PEOPLE.
IT WILL CULMINATE INTO THIS
MEETING NEXT WEEK.
WE'LL GO FROM THERE.
>> SWRUB ZOOMING?
HAVE YOU BEEN CONFERENCE
CALLING?
WHAT HAS THIS BEEN LIKE?
.
>> THERE HAVE BEEN ZOOMS,
CONFERENCE CALLS.
AND THEN NEXT WEEK WILL BE IN
PERSON AND ZOOM ACTUALLY.
BECAUSE SOME PEOPLE ARE NOT
LOCAL.
>> IF I CAN ASK YOU TO DO
SOMETHING HERE, WRITE THE TRUMP
PRESS RELEASE.
SINCE YOU WROTE A LOT OF THEM.
REACTING TO THIS MEETING THAT
YOU WILL BE HAVING NEXT WEEK.
>> OH.
THIS GROUP OF LOSERS AND RRINOS
ARE COMING TOGETHER BECAUSE THEY
WERE TERRIBLE AT THEIR JOBS.
MY SUPPORTERS WILL STAND STRONG
AND, YOU
YOU KNOW, THE MORE STATEMENTS HE
PUTS OUT WITH SILLY NAMES JUST
MEANS HE'S MORE AND MORE
CONCERNED.
I ACTUALLY LOOK FORWARD TO THAT
STATEMENT.
>> SO, STEPHANIE, THE CHAIR OF
THE JANUARY 6th COMMITTEE SAID
HE WOULD LIKE TO HEAR FROM VICE
PRESIDENT PENCE.
WE SHOULD BE CLEAR THIS WASN'T A
FORMAL OVERTURE, BUT THEY WOULD
LIKE THE FORMER VICE PRESIDENT
TO PARTICIPATE VOLUNTARILY.
DO YOU EXPECT THAT TO HAPPEN?
>> I HOPE IT WILL HAPPEN.
I THINK THAT HE HAS A LOT OF
INSIGHT.
I'M NOT GOING TO LIE, I KNOW
THAT HE'S PUT IN A VERY
DIFFICULT POSITION POLITICALLY
IN ORDER TO DO THAT.
BUT I HOPE HE WILL.
I THINK THAT THE VICE PRESIDENT
IS A GOOD MAN.
AND I HOPE HE WILL IS ALL I CAN
SAY THERE.
>> YOU HEARD MERRICK GARLAND,
THE ATTORNEY GENERAL YESTERDAY,
PROMISE HE'LL FOLLOW THIS
INVESTIGATION WHEREVER IT TAKES
HIM.
YOU KNOW THERE ARE DEMOCRATS WHO
ARE FRUSTRATED THAT THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT HASN'T AT LEAST
PUBLICLY BEEN INVESTIGATING OR
TARGETING MORE SENIOR PEOPLE.
DO YOU FEEL AS IF THAT'S A
MISSED OPPORTUNITY?
>> WELL, I DON'T KNOW THAT
THEY'RE NOT DOING THAT.
TO BUILD A CRIMINAL CASE, YOU
HAVE TO REALLY BE CAREFUL AND
FIND THE FACTS AND PUT THEM
TOGETHER.
I UNDERSTAND EVERYBODY'S
IMPATIENT.
I AM TOO.
BUT I BELIEVE THAT THEY'RE DOING
THINGS BEHIND THE SCENES THAT WE
DON'T KNOW ABOUT, AND I BELIEVE
IN THE PROCESS.
I REALLY DO.
I THINK THEY'RE JUST TAKING
THEIR TIME TO MAKE SURE THEY'RE
BUILDING CASES THAT COULD
ACTUALLY GO TO COURT AND THAT
THEY COULD ACTUALLY WIN IN.
>> HE SAID THAT THEY'RE GOING
TO -- HE BASICALLY SAID THEY'RE
GOING TO PURSUE WHATEVER IT IS.
DOESN'T HAVE TO JUST BE THE
PAWNS IN ALL OF THIS, IT COULD
BE THE ORCHESTRATERS OR THE
MASTERMINDS OF IT.
MY WORDS, NOT HIS.
HE SAID WITHIN THE LAW, RIGHT,
WITHIN THE LAW, AND THEREIN
COULD BE THE DIFFICULTY BECAUSE
AS YOU SAID THEY HAVE TO BE
BUILDING A CASE.
WHAT DOES IT MEAN IF IN THE END
THERE IS A DECISION MADE THAT
WITHIN THE LAW THEY CAN'T DO
THAT, THAT THEY ACTUALLY CANNOT
GET TO THE HEART OF THE FOLKS
WHO WERE REALLY THE ONES BEHIND
THIS?
>> I WOULDN'T BE SURPRISED TO BE
HONEST BECAUSE DONALD TRUMP AND
A LOT OF HIS CIRCLE ARE AMAZING
AT GETTING OTHER PEOPLE TO DO
THINGS.
OTHER PEOPLE TO DO THE THINGS
AND THEN THOSE PEOPLE GET IN
TROUBLE.
I MEAN, MICHAEL COHEN IS AN
EXAMPLE RIGHT THERE.
THEY'RE VERY, VERY GOOD AT THAT
MANIPULATION, WHICH, AGAIN, IS
SOMETHING I WANT TO SPEND THE
NEXT YEAR REALLY PUSHING AND
SHOWING EXAMPLES OF.
YOU KNOW, I THINK THAT
REGARDLESS OF IF THEY CAN BRING
CHARGES AGAINST THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, I THINK THAT THE
SELECT COMMITTEE IS GOING TO
SHOW, YOU KNOW, IRREFUTABLE
PROOF HE WAS BEHIND THIS, HE
WAS -- THESE PEOPLE BELIEVING IN
EVERYTHING HE SAID.
SO, PERHAPS THERE WON'T BE
CRIMINAL CHARGES.
BUT MORALLY I THINK THIS COUNTRY
IS GOING TO SEE WHAT WENT WRONG
AND THEN WE JUST ALL HAVE TO
COME TOGETHER AND NEVER, EVER,
EVER LET IT HAPPEN AGAIN.
>> LOOK, ONE OF THE CRUCIAL
QUESTIONS THE RECESSION IS WHAT
HAPPENED DURING THE 187 MINUTES
BEFORE DONALD TRUMP DECIDED TO
ASK THE PEOPLE BEHIND US WHO
WERE BEHIND US HERE TO LEAVE THE
CAPITOL.
DO YOU KNOW SPECIFICALLY WHO
PLEADED WITH TRUMP TO STOP THE
VIOLENCE DURING THE ATTACK,
IVANKA, KEVIN McCARTHY, WHO
ELSE?
>> I DON'T KNOW SPECIFICALLY.
I KNOW MRS. TRUMP DID NOT.
SO THERE'S THAT.
YOU KNOW, ALL I KNOW ABOUT THAT
DAY IS HE WAS IN THE DINING
ROOM, GLEEFULLY WATCHING ON HIS
TV AS HE OFTEN DID, LOOK AT ALL
OF THE PEOPLE FIGHTING FOR ME,
HITTING REWIND, WATCHING IT
AGAIN.
THAT'S WHAT I KNOW.
>> AND THEN FINALLY JUST BEFORE
WE LET YOU GO, STEPHANIE, YOU'RE
GOING TO HAVE THIS MEETING NEXT
WEEK AS YOU SAID WITH ABOUT 15
FORMER TRUMP OFFICIALS AS YOU'RE
TRYING TO COMBAT SOME OF THE
RHETORIC FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP.
WHAT IS THAT OFFENSIVE, THAT
INFORMATION OFFENSIVE GOING TO
LOOK LIKE?
ARE YOU TALKING ABOUT GOING ON
TELEVISION?
YOU SAID YOU WANT TO GO AROUND
THE COUNTRY AND TALK TO PEOPLE,
MAYBE A LISTENING TOUR, WHAT IS
THAT GOING TO ENTAIL?
>> THAT'S PART OF WHAT WE'RE
GOING TO TALK ABOUT NEXT WEEK
WHAT ARE THE MOST EFFECTIVE
TACTICS TO -- IN ORDER TO CARRY
THAT MESSAGE.
I THINK EVERYBODY WILL HAVE
DIFFERENT ROLES THAT THEY WILL
BE MORE EFFECTIVE AT.
SO THAT'S PART OF NEXT WEEK IS
GETTING THAT PLAN.
I'M REALLY EXCITED ABOUT IT.
I JUST THINK THAT IT WILL BE
IMPORTANT FOR PEOPLE IN THIS
COUNTRY WHO ARE STILL SUPPORTING
HIM TO HEAR FROM PEOPLE WHO
ACTUALLY WORKED WITH HIM DAY IN,
DAY OUT, WORKED WITH A LOT OF
PEOPLE IN HIS INNER CIRCLE.
WE'RE NOT GOING TO JUST TALK
ABOUT, YOU KNOW, THE FORMER
PRESIDENT, WE'RE GOING TO TALK
ABOUT THE PEOPLE WHO ARE STILL
SURROUNDING HIM AND WHO THEY
REALLY ARE.
I'M HOPING THE PEOPLE WILL TALK
TO SOMEBODY LIKE ME OR OTHER
PEOPLE WHO DID BELIEVE IN TRUMP
AND UNDERSTAND YOU CAN BE PROUD
OF HIS POLICIES, YOU CAN STILL
BE BEHIND A LOT OF THE AMERICA
FIRST POLICIES HE IMPLEMENTED,
WHICH I AM, BUT